>>> THE HOUSE VOTED TO CENSURE
PAUL GOSAR AFTER HE POSTED A
VIDEO THAT SHOWED HIM KILLING
ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ.
TWO REPUBLICANS, CHENEY AND
KINZINGER VOTED IN FAVOR OF THE
CENSURE AFTER HEATED DEBATE.
.
>> WHAT IS SO HARD ABOUT SAYING
THAT THIS IS WRONG?
THIS IS NOT ABOUT ME.
THIS IS NOT ABOUT REPRESENTATIVE
GOSAR.
BUT THIS IS ABOUT WHAT WE ARE
WILLING TO ACCEPT.
.
>> THERE IS NO THREAT IN THE
CARTOON OTHER THAN THE THREAT TO
WHAT IMMIGRATION POSES TO OUR
COUNTRY.
.
>> OUR WORK HERE MATTERS.
OUR EXAMPLE MATTERS.
THERE IS MEANING IN OUR SERVICE.
AND AS LEADERS IN THIS COUNTRY
WHEN WE IN CITE VIOLENCE WITH
DEPICTIONS AGAINST OUR
COLLEAGUES, THAT TRICKLES DOWN
INTO VIOLENCE IN THIS COUNTRY.
>> FOR DEMOCRATS, THIS VOTE
ISN'T ABOUT A VIDEO, IT'S ABOUT
CONTROL.
>> THIS IS ABOUT THIS INCIDENT
OF A MEMBER USING WHATEVER
MEDIUM YOU WANT TO SAY ON THE
PUBLIC DIME THREATENING AND
SHOWING THE KILLING OF A MEMBER
OF THIS HOUSE.
CAN'T THAT APPALL YOU, EVEN THAT
ACT?
DO YOU HAVE NO SHAME?
>> TODAY WE'RE CRITIQUING PAUL
GOSAR'S ANIME.
NEXT WEEK WE MIGHT BE INDICTING
THE WILEY E. COYOTE FOR AN
EXPLOSIVE ORDINANCE AGAINST THE
ROAD RUNNER.
>> THE RESOLUTION ON THE FLOOR
TODAY IS ABOUT ACCOUNTABILITY.
>> HERE WE GO AGAIN, CENSORING
SPEECH.
OUR RIGHT TO SPEAK, TALK, TO
COMMUNICATE, AND THEY ARE GOING
AFTER THAT TODAY BECAUSE THEY
DON'T LIKE FREEDOM.
.
>> JOINING ME NOW CNN POLITICAL
COMMENTATOR S.E. CUPP.
WHAT DID WE LEARN ABOUT THE
REPUBLICANS IN THE HOUSE?
.
>> THAT ALMOST ALL OF THEM ARE
WILLING TO STAND UP AND VOTE IN
DEFENSE OF A VIDEO ATTACKING
ANOTHER MEMBER OF CONGRESS.
AND I THINK THE BIG TAKEAWAY
HERE IS THAT THIS WILL PROBABLY
END IN REAL VIOLENCE.
I KNOW THAT BECAUSE WHEN DONALD
TRUMP AND REPUBLICANS GO AHEAD
AND IN CITE VIOLENCE, IT ENDS IN
VIOLENCE.
WE SAW THAT ON JANUARY 6th.
WE HAVE SEEN THAT IN THE DEATH
THREATS IN PEOPLE LIKE FRED
UPTON AND OTHERS.
FOR HEALTH OFFICIALS FOR
ENFORCING MASK MANDATES.
ELECTION OFFICIALS FOR REFUSING
TO CERTIFY DONALD TRUMP.
WE HAVE SEEN THE VIOLENCE.
WE HAVE SEEN THE DEATH THREATS.
THIS WILL END BADLY.
AND REPUBLICANS WILL HAVE BLOOD
ON THEIR HANDS.
>> WHY ONLY TWO THEN?
.
>> BECAUSE THERE IS NO
PUNISHMENT FOR THIS SORT OF
BEHAVIOR.
REPUBLICANS KNOW THAT KEVIN
McCARTHY IS NOT GOING TO
DISCIPLINE THEM FOR THIS
TERRIBLE, INDEFENSIBLE BEHAVE.
WHY?
BECAUSE HE WANTS TO BE SPEAKER.
IT'S THAT CRAVEN AND GROSS, BUT
IT'S NOT COMPLICATED.
>> NO.
AND GOSAR RETWEETED A TWEET WITH
THE VIDEO IN IT.
IT'S NOT LIKE IT STOPPED
ANYTHING.
.
>> NO.
>> WHAT ABOUT THE ARGUMENT --
DON BACON VOTED AGAINST CENSURE
BUT IS MORE MODERATE REPUBLICAN.
HE SAID, LOOK, WHAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN IF REPUBLICANS TAKE POWER
NEXT YEAR, WHICH COULD VERY WELL
HAPPEN, DEMOCRATS WILL GET
CENSURED LEFT, RIGHT AND CENTER
HERE.
I ASKED KHAOEU BURN AND HE SAID
WE HOPE THEY TAKE IT ON A CASE
BY CASE AND RESPONSIBLY.
>> JOHN, I LOOK FORWARD TO THE
DAY WHEN I'M SITTING WITH YOU IN
2022 OR 23rd, BECAUSE MY
CONTRACT HAS BEEN RENEWED, THEY
ARE SEEING GOOD FOR THEE BUT NOT
FOR ME.
BECAUSE ALL THE ARGUMENTS
REPUBLICANS MADE ABOUT FREE
SPEECH AND PROCESS AND THAT A
WASTE OF TIME, WE SHOULD BE
DOING MORE IMPORTANT THINGS,
WILL FALL AWAY WHEN THEY GET
POWER AGAIN.
>> I WANT TO TALK ABOUT LIZ
CHENEY AND TED CRUZ.
BY THE WAY, DID VOTE FOR CENSURE
THERE.
>> SHE DID.
.
>> SHE VOTED FOR CENSURE, NOT
TED CRUZ.
SHE ACCUSED HIM OF HAVING TRUMP
DERANGEMENT SYNDROME.
THIS IS HOW SHE RESPONDED.
>> TED USED TO SAY HE WAS A
CONSTITUTIONAL CONSERVATIVE.
BUT NOW HE IS LIKE SO DESPERATE
FOR POLITICAL APPROVAL HE WILL
EVEN ADVOCATE, SUCCESSION.
AND I THINK A REAL MAN WOULD BE
DEFENDING HIS RIGHT AND HIS
FATHER AND THE CONSTITUTION.
>> OF COURSE DONALD TRUMP
SMEARED HIS WIFE DURING THE 2016
CAMPAIGN AND SUGGESTED HIS
FATHER WAS INVOLVED IN THE
KENNEDY ASSASSINATION.
WHAT HAPPENED THERE?
.
>> LISTEN, LIZ CHENEY IS DOING
GREAT AT SORT OF CLAPPING BACK
AT THESE GUYS.
I WISH THIS WASN'T WHERE WE'RE
AT.
THEY'RE COMING FOR LIZ CHENEY IN
BELOW-THE-BELTWAYS.
I SAW SEAN HANNITY THE OTHER
NIGHT SAYING SHE WAS JUST UP ON
HER HIGH HORSE.
MEANING DEFENDING DEMOCRACY.
MEANWHILE, TED CRUZ, WELL, SHE'S
IN THE STREETS DOING THE REAL
WORK.
SESAME STREET, BY THE WAY.
FIGHTING BIG BIRD.
THIS IS WHERE THE PARTY IS AT.
LIZ CHENEY IS UP ON THE HIGH
HORSE AND TED CRUZ DOING THE
REAL WORK, FIGHTING BIG BIRD.
>> BILL MAHER WAS ON WITH CHRIS
LAST NIGHT.
>> I SAW THE WHOLE HOUR.
.
>> AND MORE OR LESS EVERYTHING
YOU'VE JUST SAID, RIGHT, BILL
MAHER SAYS EVEN WITH ALL THAT,
THIS IS STILL GOING TO HAPPEN
FOR DONALD TRUMP.
LET'S LISTEN.
>> THE REPUBLICAN PARTY, AS MUCH
AS I KEEP HEARING ABOUT, OH,
TRUMP, HE'S NOT AS RELEVANT
ANYMORE.
TRUST ME, HE'S GOING TO RUN.
ABSOLUTELY.
HE'S GOING TO GET THE
NOMINATION.
AND I CERTAINLY WOULDN'T BE
SURPRISED IF HE JUST WON THE
ELECTION.
BUT EVEN IF HE DOESN'T WIN THE
ELECTION, HE WILL SAY HE WON THE
ELECTION.
THERE IS NO DOUBT THAT HE WILL
SAY HE WON.
>> WELL, HERE'S WHERE YOU
MISSPOKE.
YOU SAID EVEN WITH ALL THAT,
MAYBE TRUMP -- NO.
BECAUSE OF ALL THAT.
IT'S BECAUSE OF EVERYTHING THAT
REPUBLICANS HAVE DONE TO
CONDITION THIS ENVIRONMENT,
MAKING NOTHING MATTER, LOWERING
THE BAR, FORGETTING ABOUT THINGS
ABOUT THINGS THAT YOU AND I CARE
ABOUT BUT NO ONE ELSE DOES.